One of the things that we have found in our
research is that in general we don't make
full use of the capacity of the human brain.
We identified that actually initially from
hearing from a couple of the POWs when they
were in solitary confinement.
They told us that when they were in solitary
confinement for years and all they had was
the ability to think that they developed unusual
cognitive capacities that they never had before
when they were in solitary confinement, like
they were essentially exercising their brain.
One individual told us he was able to multiply
eventually many numbers by many numbers, 12
numbers by 12 numbers accurately.
Never was able to do that before.
Another told us that he was able to remember
to very early times in his childhood, like
remembering the names of the students in his
kindergarten class.
Admiral Shoemaker, one of the individuals
that we came to admire a lot, built a house
in his mind nail by nail, cabinet by cabinet,
room by room and then when he got out he built
that house, and when we met him he was having
a fight with his wife because she wanted to
renovate the house and he said no way was
that going to happen.
That brought home that when you exercise your
brain and you don't have any outside distractions
because you're in solitary, you have enormous
capacities.
Our research group subsequently hearing about
this and others around the country have now
taken a tact that through specific exercises
we might be able to enhance brain plasticity,
or using more of the capacity of the human
brain.
For example, we now have a research study
in which where through exercises, through
psychological exercises are trying to retrain
the circuits that are involved in depression.
It's not a typical psychotherapy.
It's very specifically oriented toward improving
the circuits that are involved in causing
human depression.
So far there are some positive results around
that.
For certain forms of learning and memory problems,
new therapies have been developed that exercise
the human brain around learning and memory
mechanisms.
With human anxiety, practicing certain techniques
that tap into the circuits and the chemistry
of anxiety is now an area of focus.
Mindfulness therapy is an example of that.
So that's a really emerging area to develop
new therapies, non pharmacological therapies,
that exercise the human brain to improve learning
and memory problems and anxiety and problems
with depression.